this is a eurasian
eagle owl that's an owl whoa come on
there she goes i thought you said he was
cool
yeah
super anything but cool
these guys are i'm wrapped up here
actually capable of killing small deer
i don't believe that how could a bird
this size kill us little tiny oh look at
that
i said
i said i don't believe you into one
[Laughter]
they have fixed i believe you i believe
you you can they but but how a small
deer that's a large still a large crop a
fonder yeah but they'll eat things from
ducks to geese i understand that those
are smaller but how could he uh best
such a large animal well earphones are
only about five pounds when they're born
and that's when they would take them
okay and another really cool thing about
an eagle owl is that they're actually
will kill other owls and eagles if
they're threatened by them so they kill
their own kind yeah it's territory if
they see one around they're like well
that dude might kill some of the food
i'm going to eat so i'm going to take
him out
he's looking the other way what's the
noise i should be making
maybe make a bunch of makeup
on
all right we're just about out of time
and we've got to get to this last all
right
because this is going to be quite uh i'm
told quite a dangerous animal i would uh
andy where are you going
what what tell us this guy right here
what's in here is it super super gnarly
your first it's mickey roark no i'm just
kidding
you want to stay back at least six feet
from this did you hear that
all right fully venomous fully fang
what do you mean fully venomous
how much does it cost to get the venom
out before you bring it here this is
a western
diamondback rattlesnake
okay
and and
obviously a rattlesnake is known for
this right here yeah
yeah also i think the more lethal part
though is the the front now check this
out bites you and kills you now you'll
hear that if you hear that you don't do
what i'm doing it's all strike
lightning fast strike check this out
oh
oh miss
you you should get one there's one back
there you should get it killing okay
make sure you stay back
oh
here's mine you try yours try yours
he you might just think you're trying to
throw him a party
[Music]
well
we finally got to see a balloon pop
i guess i'm a real man now
you